welcome to this video against buf from
the netherlands it's their name nope
okay mmm something else maybe a king's
indian butter yeah those g3 guys yeah
they're boring I know I play the stuff
myself and what now come on even not
even see for how lame is that okay now
they can even play a five I had the idea
to play this wacky Queen 85 h 5 business
but pinner this point advances in fact
quite ok m four wide I don't want to go
b6 that's not really a good good line
let's switch back to oh come on i'm
switching back to a d5 setup maybe I can
do something on the light squares not
totally clear what a five is
accomplishing in such a structure it has
some gange em some space but other than
that it's not clear well okay I think
you should go see for nevertheless it's
it's difficult to play for anything in
this type of position I know it's not
going for that okay so see 5 or not then
I want I want some sort of porn play in
the center
hmm yeah very very weird position I want
to see do now take stuff like beef or
maybe now or this one that's um it's a
solid choice yeah i'm going to go into
push him you see going to go afore maybe
I wonder ever should play something like
b5 engine let me out come on let him
just this was there would be a risky
pre-movie a queen bee six assuming that
he will take it's not really clear that
you won't take now he does okay my main
idea was that I can now quickly develop
sorry to see that i can get my stuff out
him if I've maybe I am okay the thing
that I have in my favor is development
the only thing maybe come only five here
if five is the ramesseum I need to open
up the position and try to use and he's
playing so quickly why not taking on d5
okay night c4s Quincy five and black is
ok I think why why oh why isn't this
okay for me now what Queen B 5 I Quincy
5s or be a no then be three maybe maybe
be 3s no I can always take on I can
always take on c3 can never take on d5
right OS them
is there some check check before my I
don't think so before I can even take on
c3 I guess I cannot hmm ok to be five or
what now see for Bishop checks let's
let's check this for a moment I'm taking
here I yes Bishop t to simply and I have
no way to cover my bishop that's a real
shame if i go to d6 here Scott Bishop f4
hmm and again I have no square okay so I
need to go down what else is there okay
see for Bishop Jake's gym oh I agree was
thinking see form not that this is bad
or anything that was just not what I had
expected this sort of invites knight c6
okay
added but take it and 95 open isn't this
dangerous somehow you will just play f4
in the fraction of a second probably
between four and then 95 Wow yes copy
should be two layer come on I'm going to
do that if F for is really that great
sorry then gap so beard right yeah I can
I give the check Knight f3 and kingi to
my f sorry my voice is failing me kingi
291 yeah I don't know if this wins i
mean i don't have anything else right
now it's kind of stupid to believe it
could win yeah it can can just move the
King to h1
just got the special move okay so going
to go here now the biggest issue is
really I have absolutely no time on the
clock 38 seconds check
check any endgame he would probably win
on time this is chat really a huge
problem
King edge 1 i'm playing at five
intending rookie foyer that that is
dangerous definitely dangerous
good defense the only defense probably
he can just take the light who can just
take this piece no no no just a pleasure
sir this is not even a bluff I just I
just blundered that I mean there's no
compensation here whatsoever
I can he can even take him you can't
even take it
check check check check
check
check check I'm rowley Andrew self-made
hoops white forfeits our time yeah I
mean he was he was also playing on time
whatever I don't know ah Wow jam I
really don't know what what's going on
down who so let's let's check out I mean
it really looked I mean f4 seems to be a
good evening I was fearing that already
okay and here it is really I just draw I
guess oh oh no oh no no I can go oh I
actually saw that a bit later Queen age
three no Queen III and it is made no
Jack I had seen this idea later briefly
but I didn't see it when it was on the
board and it's made wow wow Jack Jack
gentium I'm really just fishing i can do
that was thinking that I drew a three
years defending this the comp actually
even yeah yeah yeahs wants to do this
and says that this is not not any
problem ha yeah well it is a computer
yeah I cannot do that check check here
I'm out of a lot of chicks Wow yeah what
a mess I don't know it was at least a
good fight thanks for watching